aquí tenemos dos rectas amarillas que se
intersectan y nos dan la medida de este
ángulo que es x de este que es 60 grados
y de este de acá que es 7x y a partir de
esta información queremos encontrar la
medida de este ángulo y de este ángulo y
para eso vamos a necesitar encontrar x
bueno una pista muy grande para
encontrar x consiste en darse cuenta que
estos dos ángulos son ángulos adyacentes
que forman este ángulo conjuntamente que
es un ángulo opuesto por el vértice a
este de acá déjame hacer eso con otro
color para para explicarlo más
claramente este ángulo con este ángulo
conjuntamente forman este ángulo de acá
que voy a marcar en color blanco este
ángulo de acá que es igual a este ángulo
de acá porque son ángulos opuestos por
este vértice sale entonces estos dos
ángulos deben ser iguales y por lo tanto
este ángulo que marque en blanco mide 77
x sale con esta información ya podemos
plantear una ecuación en x
si tenemos x x y le sumamos 60 grados 60
grados obtenemos 7x lo voy a poner así
con color verde esto es igual creo que
es este verde más bien es igual a 7x
sale y con esta ecuación ya podemos
encontrar el valor de x despejando lo
cómo le hacemos bueno pues ya tenemos
este 7x de este lado voy a pasar este x
de ese lado restando x de ambos lados o
sea aquí voy a restar x aquí también voy
a restar x y realizando las operaciones
me queda lo siguiente aquí la x se
cancela con la x aquí 7 x x es 6x y por
lo tanto 6x es igual a 60 grados 60
grados y esta ecuación ya la puedes
resolver mentalmente pero bueno yo lo
voy a hacer un poco más sistemático voy
a dividir entre 6 de ambos lados de modo
que aquí el 6 se cancela con el 6 y me
queda que x
y x es igual a 60 grados entre 6 o sea
es igual a 10 grados y a partir de esta
información ya podemos decir cuánto
miden todos los ángulos de la figura
este de aquí me dx este de acá por lo
tanto este ángulo es de 10 grados y este
de acá pues este de acá es 7 veces x
este de acá es de 70 grados 70 grados lo
cual tiene mucho sentido porque también
es igual a estos diez grados más estos
60 grados de acá y entonces estos dos
son iguales como 'rey como deberían de
ser por ser opuestos por el vértice